[Music]
what's up guys michael here today let's
take a trip down memory lane and explore
one of the most bitter feuds in
cinematic history no not marvel vs dc or
clint eastwood versus chairs what do you
mean shut up we're talking about the
age-old rivalry between two of the most
successful animation studios of our time
pixar vs dreamworks the battle between
these toon powerhouses all began in 1998
with two little films about two little
ants which may or may not have come from
the same idea but we'll save ip battles
for the lawyers we're talking a bug's
life and ants on face value there's
every reason to assume that these are
two versions of the same movie they
begin with the same premise a misfit ant
can't conform to the highly regimented
rules of his world but despite sharing
basically the same jumping off point the
movies go on to explore different themes
and come to very different conclusions
and in the process they explore some
very relevant economic and political
philosophies finally i'm a beautiful
butterfly no
really so let's dig down the ant hill in
this wisecrack edition on a bug's life
versus ants are all ants equal and of
course spoilers ahead for two movies
about a bunch of bugs
we've talked before about how animated
films revolving around insect colonies
can be damn effective allegories about
human societies and it's not hard to see
why insect colonies are highly efficient
rigidly structured social systems in
which each individual occupies a
specific role this makes them apt
analogies for modern societies and a
great backdrop for a plucky
non-conforming protagonist add that to
the fact that in the late 90s ants
seemed like a relatively easy animal to
bring to life with still nascent
computer animation and you can see why
this idea had legs six likes to be exact
now the shared setup of the two films
destined them to explore the conflict
between individualism and conformity but
the way the two protagonists express
their individualism and the way their
efforts pan out reflects a stark
ideological difference both movies
depict an ant colony as a highly
regimented society in which each
individual ant is a worker a member of
the nobility or in the case of ants a
soldier in a bug's life the work is
largely agricultural gathering food for
the winter months that's it that's it
good you're doing great there you go
there you go this is because the ants
have to gather enough food not only for
themselves but also for a roving gang of
grasshoppers this is loosely based off
one of aesop's fables the ant colony in
a bug's life thus resembles a mostly
pre-industrial colonial society where
the colonists the grasshoppers are
extracting natural resources from the
ants through the exploitation of their
labor that's not unlike the way colonial
powers like france exploited the
resources and labor of algeria in
exchange the grasshoppers offer a vague
veil of protection from other scary bugs
who might do the ants even more harm
listen if you don't keep your end of the
bargain then i can't guarantee your
safety here the exploitation of the ants
is being painted as being in their best
interest this too is not unlike the way
colonial powers like france justify
their colonization by saying that they
were actually acting in the algerian's
best interest specifically by quote
unquote civilizing them when they were
in actuality violently oppressing them
importantly a bug's life also shows a
society that's steeped in tradition and
highly resistant to change with flick
gone you can't mess anything up when
flick introduces a machine that can make
gathering food go faster he's dismissed
and mocked this is my new idea for
harvesting grain no more picking
individual kernels you can just cut down
the entire stock
we don't have time for this exactly this
lightly evokes some of the growing pains
of industrialization where machines
drastically changed the skills needed to
perform tasks that humans had been doing
for centuries in contrast ants depicts
the colony as an explicitly industrial
society complete with unreliable public
transit workers are made to constantly
dig tunnels haul dirt and form wrecking
balls out of their own bodies the entire
colony resembles a modern factory floor
complete with motivational posters that
discourage idleness the workers perhaps
uncoincidentally resemble miners an
industry famous for widespread labor
strikes and brutal crackdowns on them
the other faction of the colony in ants
is the military soldiers in the society
enjoy a higher social status than the
lowly workers why'd i have to be born a
worker
you soldiers get all the glory plus you
get to go out in the world you know you
meet interesting insects you get to kill
them even though the selection process
to determine their status is comically
arbitrary
uh worker
soldier
this emphasis on a strong military along
with a highly productive workforce
resembles how a lot of industrial
societies organize themselves after the
first world war the mass mobilization of
an unprecedented number of military
personnel occurred alongside an equally
unprecedented increase in industrial
production this created nations where
nearly every citizen was involved in at
least one of those aspects of society
this made for even stronger national
identities we see this same sense of
nationalism throughout the society
depicted in ants where every member
exists primarily to contribute to the
colony rather than to realize their own
ambitions a soldier knows that the life
of an individual ant doesn't matter
what matters is the colony from these
two highly homogenous societies we get
our two heroes flick and z both
exemplify individualism in the face of
an overwhelmingly conformist environment
for flick this is expressed through his
ingenuity and inventiveness allah his
new harvesting machine but his genius is
unappreciated by the ruling class who
wants him to simply fall in line and
contribute to the common cause of the
colony in this way flake seems to evoke
the ideals of author ein rand her novel
the fountainhead centers around an
architect who also struggles to bring
his new ideas to fruition in an
overwhelmingly conformist society near
the end of the novel the architect gives
a speech that encapsulates rand's
philosophy of individualism stating the
great creators the thinkers the artists
the scientists the inventors stood alone
against the men of their time every
great new thought was opposed every
great new invention was denounced
according to rand the wealth of nations
was created by these indispensable
innovators and any attempt to stifle
their brilliance was an attack on their
individual liberty this proved a very
convenient philosophy if you were one of
these innovators and that is still
enjoyed by certain space traveling union
busting tax evading gazillionaires today
zee on the other hand is not a man of
the mind at least in the randian sense
he's simply a disaffected worker whose
role in industrial society has rendered
him insignificant the whole system makes
me feel
insignificant
excellent you've made a real
breakthrough i have
yes z
you are insignificant z feels utterly
unfulfilled as a worker for the colony
and longs for a life where he can be his
own insect philosopher karl marx might
have said he was alienated from his work
marx argued that industrial capitalism
not only alienates the worker from the
product of their labor it also alienates
them from their own agency and humanity
reducing the individual to nothing more
than a cog in the grand machine of
industrialism the film is not subtle
about invoking marx's philosophy a
worker can't do anything except work
yeah it's not like we got a choice
unlike its disney pixar counterpart the
dreamworks production is much more
explicit in its political themes it's
the workers who control the means of
production it even takes subtle shots at
randy and philosophy in its imagery
throughout the film we see a statue that
depicts an ant carrying a large ball of
dirt on its back the statue is likely a
direct reference to the statue of atlas
that adorns the cover of rand's seminal
work atlas shrugged but replacing the
celestial sphere carried by the mythical
titan with the ant equivalent of a
boulder also invokes a different greek
myth the punishment of sisyphus who is
made to continuously push a boulder up a
hill
only to have it roll back down once he
gets to the top a symbol of the virtues
of industrialism thus becomes a symbol
of the futility of fruitless labor this
neatly sums up z's outlook on his life
within the colony as well as marx's
critique of industrial capitalism
already we can see how these two heroes
embody almost contradictory philosophies
while still both being motivated by
individualism in the face of conformity
both protagonists embark on pretty
standard heroes quests and both seem to
succeed pretty quickly albeit only
through misleading their fellow ants no
i i just you lied flick you lied to her
you lied to the colony you lied to me
after some humiliation both heroes
eventually take on their oppressors
inspire the masses and ultimately rely
on the strength of their communities and
their sheer numbers to vanquish the bad
guys in this way both protagonists
inspire their colonies to rise up in a
revolutionary act against oppressors
they had long obeyed without question i
know what you're thinking these are the
same movie but they're really not trust
us we're going somewhere with this sure
the two films have different plot twists
different symbolism and different cringy
flirting between worker aunt and
princess we need to talk too much
[Music]
which i
think i'm about to become this strong
silent type this is of course made all
the cringier by the casting but we
digress but what's most interesting to
us are the film's two conclusions about
these acts of revolution and the new
world orders they result in a bug's life
ends with the ants overthrowing their
colonial oppressors adopting flake's
harvesting technology and generally
living happily ever after this
reiterates the idea of great men in the
randian tradition who should be listened
to by virtue of them being great the
subtle hints of inequality go further
the princess gets her crown suggesting
that the rigid order within the anthill
will remain largely the same even if the
ants are now more efficient gatherers
who can sneak in an occasional siesta
ants on the other hand does something
arguably more interesting notably the
villainous warrior ant's evil plan is to
use the anthill's new expanded tunnel to
flood the anthill and drown the lowly
workers here the supposed progress of
expanding the anthill and making the
colonies stronger relies on the
destruction of all the workers who made
it possible in the first place while
technology in a bug's life makes things
indisputably better progress in ants
ends up threatening the lives of all the
workers this too is marxist and its
condemnation of endless economic
progress at the expense of the workers
who enable that progress ants seems to
get that you can't disconnect technology
and industry from political power
ultimately a bug's life suggests that
the class order of your average ant hill
is perfectly fine so long as you're not
being oppressed by creatures twice your
size monarchy good colonialism bad on
the other hand ants suggest that the
system itself is fundamentally broken a
bug's life depicts outside forces i.e
grasshoppers as the problem but ants
suggest that class structures within the
colony are to blame for oppression
adding to that a bug's life never really
questions the contention that the
princess's life is more valuable than
that of a worker hand indeed the colony
watches flick get beaten up by a very
scary grasshopper for a while without
intervening it's only when the princess
throws herself in front of him that they
all rally in contrast the conflict in
ants is fundamentally about the
disparities in power and opportunities
afforded to ants based on their
birthright as workers soldier or
nobility z perhaps not coincidentally
the last letter of the alphabet stands
up to the princess and demands to be
treated with respect i order you to stop
worker hey i got a name okay it's z and
ultimately the film champions the equal
importance of every ant in contributing
to the survival of the colony this
emphasis on the inherent value and
equality of every individual is in line
with the tradition of marxist humanism
or in this case antism but interestingly
or depressingly whether or not you stand
marx ants doesn't do what a bug's life
does it doesn't really offer a solution
to the problems faced by its anthill in
the conclusion all the main character
says is there you have to your average
boy meets girl boy likes girl boy
changes underlying social order story
however the film never really tells us
what the existing social order was
replaced with
z does note that the anthill has been
rebuilt and now has an indoor swimming
pool while this is probably a joke about
the flood in the previous scene you
could charitably interpret it to mean
that the workers might get some more
leisure time going forward kind of like
how you can play ping pong at your
60-hour a week startup job still we
don't get a definitive conclusion about
how you can avoid oppressive social
structures entirely in the context of an
anthill or allegorically in the context
of human society in this way although
ants is certainly the more radical of
the two films it arguably does itself a
disservice by failing to show that there
is indeed another way in a way the
conclusion arguably reflects an overall
lack of political imagination in the
west to posit an alternative to
industrial capitalism or as the line
that is often attributed to frederick
jameson goes it's easier to imagine the
end of the world than the end of
capitalism ants claims that the ants
rallied to build a new world but fails
to imagine what that new world might
look like but what do you think are we
over analyzing a couple of fun silly
kids movies about ants or can we find
surprisingly deep meditations on modern
life and even the smallest of places
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for all your support and
be sure to check out our podcast crush
that subscribe button like it's a fully
conscious self-actualized ant and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you